Ну багато чого думаєш
Що чогось не зробив Не наважився бо
думав а що там буде або ще буде час а
насправді є момент
цінуй його живе ним суто
[музика]
як знайшли вже ту переправу
я думав як мій організм Буде на це все
реагувати але це ще було на Донеччині Ми
стояли на позиціях і
артилерійські залпи дуже часто
відбувалися обстріли були найдовшого
обстріли пам'ятаю був 4 години мені ще
Так запам'яталось що
я за чотири години своїм побратимом
викурили майже пачку сигарет на двох
тому що ну неможливо було
навіть підняти голову а насправді
москалі прикривали просто свій відхід
своєї техніки але от ми сиділи 4 години
і думали чого нас ніхто не прикриває і
не дає відповідь А на ранок Ми почули те
що ту техніку яку вони відводили
прикриваючись оцим
артилерійським обстрілом наші хлопці
імерсами догнали в точці збору і вщент
розбили Ну то я кажу хлопцям що готовий
кожної ночі витримувати такий
обстріл але би просто це приносили
користь і був з того результату
[музика]
ми були на позиції і В нас закінчилися
запаси харчів і води і з двома моїми
побратимами
вирішили піти в на пункт де
безпосередньо звозили їжу і харчі Ну і
ми йшли там достатньо довго була
дистанція і в один момент ми почули що
летить над нами Дрон Я ще так кажу до
хлопців що
Дрон треба десь сховатися но ми вже були
на такій ділянці що особливо вже й не
було
де нам І переховатися тому ми дійшли до
кінця і Буквально за дві хвилини почав
працювати Танчик ну з кожним разом все
ближче і ближче Але знову завдячуючи
хлопцям
я Наскільки я знаю з 95-ї Бригади вони
цей Танчик послали вслід за російським
кораблям недовго він по нас працював
[музика]
та війна До речі
має свій особливий запах якщо ми
говоримо про запах пороху так по одному
пахне запах залишених кацапських трупів
які були просто кинуті і
Ну до речі вражений був Коли ми зайшли
на одній позиції і ну свійська худоба
свині так доїдали безпосередньо
цих років Ну але в принципі
на це вони і заслуговують тут нічого
дивного в цьому немає
вразило кількість
тої тих артилерійських снарядів які по
нас випускали я Одної ночі був
підірвався з бліндажа бо Ну так мені
здали що це були
фосфорні обстрі тобто вони били по
позиціях насправді на ранок вияснилось
що це вони цим магнієм зарядом він не
настільки небезпечний але все-таки
переживали за себе за хлопців щоб ніхто
не дай Бог не попав під таку штуку щоб
не нанесли якоїсь шкоди е-е
для
організму та було багато моментів коли
сидиш в щілині в окопі бо є обстріл і я
в темноті відчув що щось прилетіло А ну
але в темноті не розібрав би не було з
міста навіть підсвічувати шукати А на
ранок знайшов кусок
осколка такий добрячий Ну але він вже
правда кінетичної сили не мав він просто
закотився в око прямо мені біля ноги
[музика]
така історія знаєте що мене вразило
найбільше ми коли от буквально коли
відбувся оцей Харківський Контрнаступ
так і ми буквально декілька днів після
цього заїхали через Ізюм далі на свої
позиції І от ми зупинились бо шукали
дорогу як приїхати далі І коли підбігали
до тебе діти і просили їжі цукерки ну
таке моторошне відчуття зрештою те що
вони роблять з нашим населенням з з
людьми тут ну це це дикий це не
піддається жодному поясненню ще дивно
було були населені пункти в якій ми
заходили на зачистку села і Ну я не
особливо релігійна людина Але тим не
менше що вони роблять з церквами того ж
самого Московського патріархату і який
вони безлад і взагалі що там залишається
після них церквах це також
залишає багато таких точок для для думок
І взагалі з якою метою і що Вони
наслідують І взагалі які в них цінності
кожен вірить в те що він вірить Знаєте
тут насправді залишається вірити в
самого себе в хлопців побратимів які
стоять поруч з собою і Це додає
впевненості тому що ти бачиш тілиться
бачиш настрою так що
от я наприклад коли обстріли
відбуваються в мене є отак
ланцюжок такий подарований однією
людиною для мене Дорогою я його так в
руки тримаю і собі сиджу перечікується і
весь момент
[музика]
товариство їде на ноль заїжджаємо в
складі такої
висоти
і Руслан Євгенович
їдемо
на позиціях насправді весело нема такої
гнітючої обстановки є звичайно люди які
важко важче переносять ситуацію Так там
багато чого додумують накручують А ну
більше мірі дуже багато людей
це на переводяться на позитивку ці всі
будні там та перебування цей ну і
особисто по собі скажемо є негатив що я
почав більше палити Хоча до початку
війни взагалі не курив а є позитив те що
армія І перебувань тут дозволив мені
добряче схуднути
демобілізувався став підтягнуть ще Ну
зрештою так цього і це все виглядає бо
до позиції треба образно дойти донести
свій рюкзак в амуніції так занести якісь
боєприпаси
[музика]
Ну 20 кг десь орієнтовно
всі кажуть що якась різка борода бо чого
вона рижа насправді
волосся на голові в мене іншого кольору
але
Я собі думаю що мені тепліше з бородою
[музика]
а складається з особистості і кожна
особистість ну на війні Якщо хоче
виділитись там чи бородою чи якоїсь
зачіскою чи чимось іншим ну це його
право
[музика]
Ну якщо всі пам'ятаєте що відбувалося
24 лютого відчуття були такі що їх
неможливо було описати і контролювати
першим ділом я завіс свого брата 24-го
числа бо він вже не по контракту був
служив в теобороні Ну і на другий день з
своїм другом дитинства вже 25 числа Ми
стояли військкоматі ніхто не розумів що
насправді відбувається але було чітке
розуміння того що щось зробити потрібно
Ну і що я повинен бути тут
до того Я працював на будівельному
заводі великому в Тернополі був
заступником директора
перед тим до цієї посади я був 5 років
головою одного з найбільших населених
пунктів
в Тернопільському районі Великої
Березовиці
та й зрештою та 4 лютого свої корективи
багато планів було але
плани трошки змінилося Я думаю що ми їх
не було є багато штатів які треба
закрити особисто
ми приїхали до
місцевого клубу який також постраждав
від артилерійських обстрілів До речі
дуже
символічно ви ж бачите що більше
половини вулиці в будь-якої те що я
зауважую населених пунктах
Вона носить грунтія
комуністичне і вулиця Чкалова здавалося
в Україні вже давно триває цей процес
декомунізації а тим не менше
[музика]
Радянської армії
Я думаю вони його точно не для сценок
вертепу використовували
[музика]
харківщина Донеччина луганщина у цій
території безпосередньо де ми були де ми
звільняємо ми спілкуємося з людьми так
звичайно не можна всіх ставити
під одну лінійку але
електоральну вони ще завжди переважали
центр і захід України і вони вибирали
оцю проросійську владу яка постійно їм
накручувала на мотиви і це зрештою
результат
результату того всього що відбувалося
оце насаджування
російське стільки років Це є результат
цього всього Ну Україна якщо знаєте Ми
забули голодомор і все те що радянська
влада робила з нашими патріотами
дисидентами взагалі з простим мирним
населенням якщо ми Після цієї війни
е-е буде ще в когось хоча якась
мінімальна думка це все забуте то ціни
цій людині немає це треба пам'ятати
розказувати е-е що
ну Росія це наш ворог просто
споконвічний Знаєте яка в нас ще так
приваблю мені на думку ситуація мого
батька рідний брат Він вже дуже довгий
час живе в Росії в Тюмені так і оце коли
відбулося події 21 24 числа батько на
якийсь там другий чи третій день з кинув
йому фотографії того що вони робили в
містах на Київщині
і Він подивився декілька фотографій ну
видно що відмітка була що людина їх
проглянула І після того навіть не
виходив на контакт
е-е і ну взагалі навіть не питав як ми і
що ми як
[музика]
До речі мій рідний брат молодший від
мене служить зі мною Ми Коли там вже 4
місяці ми ще в Тернополі знаходили за це
все відбувалося служили то навіть
дивувались командири Як так з одної хати
дворідних братів могли взяти в один
підрозділ
також переживає за нього постійно Бо
знаєте як старший брат дивлюсь що він
там де він
війна мені додала очевидно впевненості
можливо дуже багато сидиш аналізаєш
речей які зробив або Які взагалі не
встиг зробити є особистий гештальт
створити сім'ю
так що
треба на версію
І знаєте цінність моменту щастя розумієш
коли це стає спогадом з минулого і Отут
в цих умовах як не як думок дуже багато
завжди говорив що можна втікти
від там правосуддя від чогось іншого але
від думок в голові є твого особистого я
от наприклад чого Бо я повинен бути не
тут і в такому іншому плані від думок ти
нікуди не кричав так що
Хай серія називається кімі на війні
кіміцом і позивний це абревіатура
повного прізвища імені по Батько стукіля
Михайла Ігорович Хай буде так